Bố của tổng thống Mỹ đường năng trám về tối hộ thư thuê quan, đánh giống bốc chuyển từ thương lượng sang án đặt trong chính sách thương mại của Mỹ.
Thay vì kéo sài đàn phán, tổng thân trân nhận mạnh sẽ cửa thông báo chực tiếp đến các khu saa về mức thuê cao kỳ lục.
A dụng ngay từ ngày 1 chiến năm bài nếu không đặt thật thận.
Chúng khi một số khu saa đa đạt được các bức tính nhất định, nhiều ăn, kỳ thật thận, cách sản thẩm, tối với Mỹ, cho lĩnh vực ổ tổng và hàng khổng vụ chủ.
Thì nhiều đối tá khác vẫn đang loài hoai tìm điểm thân bằng.
Eo nữ lực đàn phán để tránh nếu thuy ai ăn lắm phần trăm đến nếu mấy phần trăm, bởi thép nhau mở vỡ tổ.
Đồng thời muốn Mỹ nhận bộ cho các lĩ vực trọng yếu dựa phần và công nghệ cao.
Chúng quốc và Mỹ chỉ đàn được một thật thận tạm thơi mang tình chiến thật, chùi yếu nhằm hạn như tình hình.
Những bản và ăn quốc vẫn chưa thể bảo đạm miến chủ thế, dù đã kiếp tè sờ đổi với Mỹ.
Con đàn phán Mỹ, ăn đàn đình trẻ cho thay mất độ phút tạm khi phải cân đối lựa íng nông nghiệp và công nghiệp.
Chỉ lực ăn được thời gian mà Mỹ ch hiện khai cho thay sảo ý độ sự dụng thế quan như đàn bày để bộ các nước nhận bộ.
Mất thời gian mùng chỉ nào bày đủ đạm ra như một công cộ gây xe khác.
Không chỉ khiến cân nước phải tăng tất đàn phán mà còn khả lĩnh vị thế chủ đập của Mỹ trong các vòng thứ lượng.
Thế giới hiện đã bị quán và của đô chính chỉ kinh tế mới.
Trong đó, thương mại là phát thương, về nâng lực ứng biến và quay lực chế lực.